NBC News has a report about the person
of the year maybe you've heard uh
already the news the big news says no
single person this year has captivated
public conversation quite like Taylor
Swift so much so the Time Magazine has
named her its 2023 person of the year
I'm not a Taylor Swift fan and yeah her
music is vapid and annoying but I think
it makes sense that she's person of the
year like I heard that and I thought
okay yeah makes sense sure I could see
that and then I see the reaction from a
lot of people on the right this is how's
it Taylor Swift what do you mean what do
you mean how's it Taylor Swift didn't
she have like three number one albums
this year the the top three albums are
all hers and uh she had a tour the
biggest tour of all time and a you know
one of the biggest selling one of the
one of one of the top uh grossing films
of the year